big changes are in store for fans of The
Walking Dead
in season 9 the series will lose stars
Andrew Lincoln and lauren cohan and a
new showrunner steps in to take the
story to new places that these
alterations bode well for the AMC series
no one knows yet but a slew of theories
and rumors have hinted it where the
Walking Dead will go next let's unpack
the details two brothers fighting Rick
and Daryl's camaraderie has been a core
part of the show for years but that may
not be the case in season 9 rumors have
been swirling that Daryl and Rick's
bromance might be compromised over
Rick's controversial decision to spare
negan's life does this mean the two will
become enemies before Rick's final bow
not according to Norman Reedus they
fight and they disagree on things but
it's like two brothers fighting they
always will have each other's back but
they don't necessarily agree on
everything a second time jump according
to Uproxx rumors are circulating
regarding two shifts in time for season
9 one of a couple years and another
longer one of four or five years the
second time jump could help further the
decayed tone new showrunner Angela Kang
previously teased to Entertainment
Weekly saying will explore what happened
is man-made objects and structures
breakdown infrastructure like roads and
bridges are changing and crumbling and
we'll also explore what happens as
resources are getting low new loves
along with a hefty bump in pay
Rita's will receive top billing once
Andrew Lincoln makes his exit where that
sort of scrutiny it's hard not to wonder
if fans will finally see Daryl make a
love connection in season 9 there are
many theories rumors and requests
regarding Daryl's future from a deeper
connection to Carol to a brand new love
interest The Hollywood Reporter even
posed a compelling possibility
what if Daryl finds a man to love the
trade suggested a love connection
between him and Aaron fire or the wind
make it or not
if we do it together we have to he's not
the only one with a possible new romance
The Nerdist has theorized at Alton one
of the reformed saviors might be the TV
version of the comics Dante which might
mean that he could be a new romantic
partner for Maggie one definitely
confirmed love story is between Carole
and king Ezekiel photos from the new
season showed Carole and the king
sharing a tender moment and a subsequent
trailer shows the two sharing his smooch
father Gabriel's second sight after the
trials he endured in season eight it's
looking like father Gabriel will step
confidently into the role of holy man
once the new episodes premiered leap
images reveal Gabriel who looks to be
completely blind in one eye donning a
classic looking southern preacher
outfits
whatever he lacks in physical sight team
may make up for with religious clarity
according to bleeding cool Gabriel will
be the one helping Jadis transition to
her new home in Alexandria a new leader
with Ric's death presumably looming
speculation regarding Daryl's leadership
role has grown but as Norman Reedus told
TV Line the rumors of Darrell taking
over for Rick are just not true that's
not a two story Rick is the quarterback
of this football team he's always been
he always will be so if Daryl won't be
taken over as leader who will well
there's been a worthy successor under
our noses this entire time Rick himself
has already said who he wants to take
over for him as leader if anything
happens and if it's me who doesn't make
it you're gonna have to lead the others
forward it's an idea that's backed up by
what Angela Kang told II W about the
female characters we're gonna see our
women really step up and we're gonna
show a lot of stories about leadership
with Maggie we've shown with Carol and
they're gonna go toe-to-toe with each
other and with our men unfortunately if
Michonne does step up as leader it may
not be forever
Danai gurira star is steadily on the
rise with plenty of movie roles which
puts her continued Walking Dead future
in question when pressed on Michonne's
future in Alexandria the new showrunner
said Guerrera is definitely a series
regular this season as for what happens
after season nine though Kane said
plainly that is out of my realm
a new bat man the question of how rick
grimes will be written out of The
Walking Dead's 9th season still looms
large will he live will he die we simply
wander off into the wilderness to allow
for cameos and later seasons Lincoln has
confirmed that is coming back with the
intention of directing an episode in
season 10 but as for an actual
appearances Rick no one knows but one
thing we do know is that he'll be using
the time he has left to brutalize some
more zombies with a shiny new weapon
inspired by none other than his arch
nemesis negan promotional materials for
the new season show a grey bearded Rick
Grimes join with a bat-like weapon on
the shows previews it's clear he knows
just how to use it - a dead deputy
returns of all the long-lost characters
who could be brought back into the
Walking Dead's fold for Season 9 the
return of Jon Bernthal Shane was
probably the least expected after all
he's been dead for over six seasons and
Bernthal has had plenty of other roles
to keep him busy in the meantime however
the actor was spotted near the Atlanta
Georgia area during the seasons summer
production his appearance set off a rash
of speculation that he might be making a
cameo as Lincoln preps for his exit /
Thals returned to the show was confirmed
soon after though the exact details of
his role reprisal have been kept close
to the vest frenemies
Rick's decision to let negan live after
the all-out war with the Savior's might
come back to bite him in more ways than
one not only has he earned the ire of
his friends with this moment of
undeserved mercy but now he's gonna have
to actually deal with Nikken although
Kang has revealed that the former
enemies might have a lot more in common
than one might expect Rick goes down
there and it's parked there opee and
park gloating like they're just trying
to work their way through it like they
both feel in some ways like dinosaurs
after the war
rick has already been known to have
trouble making solid leadership
decisions in the past so one has to
imagine that having negan in his ear
probably won't be too helpful
Maggie's happy ending even though Coen
will be departing the show things might
just be looking up for Maggie in the new
season the previews for season 9 show
that her baby will finally join the
world after so many seasons of Mackey's
pregnancy with Lauren Cohen's impending
exit from the series ahead though fans
might be tempted to fear for Maggie's
well-being
however Coen is hinted that her care
story isn't over in other words Maggie
might someday make a comeback so don't
count her out just yet unfriendly new
faces with two major characters on the
way out and a lot of time hopping ahead
it's probably no surprise that season 9
will introduce a bevy of new characters
for starters there's Samantha Morton as
alpha the leader of a group of creepy
zombie impersonators called the whispers
she'll be joined by Ryan Hurst as alpha
second-in-command beta and Cassidy McLin
C as Lydia alphas daughter the show will
also introduce Brett Butler and John
Finn as Tammy and Earl a pair of hilltop
residents meanwhile Elodie Matsuura and
Nadia hill Kerr will star as yo miko and
magnum two more characters straight from
the comics other names joining the fold
are lauren written off as connie and dan
fogler is luke we'll just have to wait
and see if any of these new additions
are able to fill the void left by Rick
and Maggie the helicopter when Rick
originally saw the helicopter overhead
near the beginning of season 8 many
thought it was a hallucination
[Music]
but as the tail continued to unravel
audiences saw that the scavenger Jadis
had a connection to the copter the
timing of the helicopters appearance
could be a possible introduction of the
Commonwealth storyline from the comics
however it seems that alpha and the
whispers are also on their way so season
9 of The Walking Dead might be blending
multiple comic storylines and timelines
together the addition of alpha might
finally answer a long lingering question
about the prevalence of the letter A
that's been seen scattered throughout
the previous seasons gang has promised
that the significance of the letter will
come into view in season 9 telling fans
that it might have something to do with
Jadis Jadis might have made some
alliances before but does she have
another master controlling that
helicopter after all we'll see when the
Walking Dead Season 9 arrives on October
7
[Music]